I know a lot of people there first like
you know version of listening to Lady
Marmalade was the pink and krysta all
that version but mine actually I
actually you were my first like that I
have people that showed me really great
music when I was a kid right but my
first version of hearing was you was
your version of legendary dashing Nona
Hendryx yeah but did you know I heard
that you didn't know what that song
meant I just knew that it was a
phenomenal like a hook you get to where
bully will do jamming watch this one and
then later I found that that nuns
thought we were bad people
the nuns we're singing a song about a
hooker oh my I said what is it what
hooker I just know I love that that
melody yeah and the the sound itself and
so I found out that they were upset and
I said here's the deal
you don't take a mattress from a hooker
let her make our money I will not stop
talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this